watch this video to master
ushiro kaiten kami
in the previous episode we learned
maiukami or maya kaitlyn kami the front
floor
in this video i'm gonna show you ushiro
kaiten kemi backroll
which is the exact reverse version of
the front roll
let's start on the ground the most
important thing is to avoid any contact
between your head
and the floor in aikido we don't want to
roll over the head like a somersault but
we roll over the shoulder
first i'm gonna show it on the left side
so
left knee up right knee down and it's
important to have your
knee and the shoulder on the same line
i'm gonna
extend my left arm and the hand goes
on on the opposite direction i'm going
to use my right hand to protect the hand
and when i roll the left knee goes just
right over the left shoulder
like this okay
the angle of the arm is very important
if your arm is too high
you won't be able to roll and if your
arm is too low you may fall to the side
so please have your arm extended uh to
the side
like this 90 degree so you can do coming
like
this now i'm gonna turn so you guys can
see
from the back angle check that my head
won't hit the mat
like this and now from the front angle
the previous video we learned
a frontugami like this
and now i'm gonna do the exact same
thing i won't
extend my arm to the side but keep it
front of myself
and just roll backwards on the other
side
make a circle chin on the chest
and roll nice and slow
then backwards
and very important that my head won't
hit the mat
like this and now from standing
first myokami the front row
make a circle
and now i'm gonna do the exact same
thing backwards
at the beginning it's very important to
have your hips high enough
so it's gonna be easy to stand up
again
if it's still difficult i recommend you
to first
to get into a torque crunch position
like this or sunkyo if you prefer
japanese and
you can stand up straightly on the other
side
and gradually using the momentum
extend your back leg in the air
you will become able to do the back roll
just as you did the front row
on the other hand ushiro kaitlin kami is
a very challenging ukami
in aikido aikido kami or whatever you
are learning
it's better to do as many options as it
is possible
through gaming practice we learn how to
control
and how to move our body how to move
more
how to move better how to move with more
freedom
and how to move with more understanding
thank you for watching if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe see you in
the next video
[Music]
you